une production du studio sfr mené au
sans filtre présenté par caisse me
lebeau de castes où on parle de ce qu'on
veut nous inviter date site du ps quand
tu es avec moi dôme plan on a encore
évidemment notre code promo qui roule
pour qu'un smic et le sans filtre pour
20% de rabais
c'est notre partenaire officiel on les
attend on trouve c'est une compagnie qui
est qu'on adore représentait en fait
puis on vous encourage à aller voir ce
qu'ils font dans le fond si vous voulez
avant qu'est ce qui sort de l'ordinaire
et à chaque qu'est ce que vous achetez
ils plantent des armes en fait pour
lutter contre les changements
climatiques donc tout le monde
demong a littéralement cette semaine des
as we know more suivent tous la casse on
a reçu les deux membres du podcast
couple ouvert
thomas levac et c'était fatigant de la
dame à la voix qui probablement la
personne après nous qui passent le plus
de temps après nicole passent le plus de
temps ici parce qu'injuste de bakassi
par semaine ici est tellement qu'il est
devenu sous le podcast qui avait été
controversé comme n'étaient pas tous nos
instants qui avait apprécié son passage
on s'était beaucoup le monde quitte
après un portemanteau été happé pas mal
comme à 10 puis mais aujourd'hui c'était
super le fun on ne parlait pas la fin
rappelez vous que beaucoup de choses qui
sont dix ans et pas de casque qui sont
deux immenses terrains les podcasts
vraiment content et on est grand on
n'est absolument pas prendre tout au
pied de la lettre
mais c'était vraiment plaisant on ne rit
on eût dit von avec eux on a parlé de
maman mon envie folle détracteurs pour
nous on a parlé de ne parler de coup on
a parlé apport de moins d'enfants non ne
parle et où beaucoup on ne parlait on a
parlé de coup pouvoir évidemment leur
projet on a parlé de comment ils sont
rencontrés dans ville anecdotes de leur
rencontre au gala des oliviers et les
jeux légendaires fait que vous allez
pouvoir rire et encore une fois comme de
midi c'est de l'humour donc
sans plus attendre les remercie nos
sponsors et puis après ça on vous laisse
la conversation
bonne écoute le pack cadeau aujourd'hui
est présenté par vive que vous
connaissez il fondit smoothie fondé
pleut aussi fondé des dîners et soupers
heures mais là c'est l'été un beau souci
frais ça fait du bien puis plusieurs
façons il dit que de déguster on peut
les faire dans son petit traditionnel on
peut faire en bol smoothie on peut le
faire en crème glacée et on peut même le
faire en pop ce que les ph essayé un
proxy calmons nous comment t'as fait ça
j'ai avec moi une rondelle de smoothie
avis et un rack de boxe écoles fixe que
je vais facile de prendre la rondelle je
vais la mettre un petit peu de lait
d'avoine dames on me sort j'avais un
coup les soeurs dans mes bras cabot
psycho de naissance congélateur puis je
vous reparle après ah ouais bon avec le
pic saint loup y es tu on a un code
promo pour vous pour tous les produits
chez un vip qui est le sans filtre
podcast 10 pour 10 $ de rabais sur votre
1ere commande vive fait qu'aller voir
sapmer servi pour le super partenaire
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ça roule hier bienvenue au sans filtre
c'est annie encore un peu rebelle et
cochons ouais c'est ce qu'on préfère
casser fait un bonjour merci sa sacoche
avec un nouveau micro les voix sont plus
[ __ ] un projet jamais fait ça mais
vous voyez quelqu'un au lycée doit être
très bon je connais un pays qui est le
seul au début on commence à se voyant
juke puis ont jamais été capable
d'arrêter de vous voyez bien qu'ils ont
essayé au genre si oui on se tutoie le
terrain du trou woods factice parler aux
lys vouvoyait c'est sur walk est
est-ce qu'ils aient voulez-vous dessus
[Rires]
cash et moi dans la bouche de ce test
est seul mais la moselle oui j'ai connu
je me rappelle juste plus et qui après
l'avoir dérangé tout le podcast comme un
défi mais j'y tiens on avait cette
discussion là parce qu'on a reçu
on a reçu deux personnes qui en rentrant
airs anticipe le sicom est ce qu'on peut
se tutoyer ouais pas de problème on peut
se tutoyer goût de plus la seconde qu'on
est assis sa tombe au bout de suite
automatiquement comme je t'ai je ne
contrôle pas le trait juste parce que
c'est comme ceux qui ont essayé de
mettre le doigt sur c'est quoi le
facteur qui fait que certaines personnes
que c'est vous automatiquement c'est le
monsieur v comme 55 ans c'est vous
messieurs 45 pendant que s'arrêter
dessus
la notoriété il y avait aussi un à un un
statut du métier mais c'est ça c'est
flou amman et c'est comme le gouvernant
matic mans mais on sait pas exactement
où voir ce que je voulais avec ça c'est
qu'il sera emmené mettons je couchais
avec une madame qui se hâtent facteurs
le père qui fait que mais dont j'ai le
goût automatique
j'ai pas qu'est ce que je ferais set
mais est ce que cet excellent et
d'envisager les choses fixer mais non
c'est pas pareil que toi
non c'est ce génial péché que maintenant
mes chèques s'empresse pas un problème
mais c'est une situation à laquelle j'ai
des gens que je connais qui n'en a que
les semaines puis s'ils ont le même
réflexe que moi d'appeler les personnes
plus âgées vous doit se retrouver que la
même situation
moi j'ai un échec de plus que toi tu
[Rires]
oui
ah ouais ouais c'est quoi le plus plus
loin et allez y mettant des m23 et elle
avait 37 a tout appris
amap a tout appris mais reach la
sexualité ce très simple c'est que je
n'ai pas grand chose très répétitif
ainsi beaucoup flotte
on écoute latéralement et voyez bien
faire l'amour il m'a tout appris le
métier doit l'api après le mot pas
madame pendant puis sort bien sûr bien
se passer ou apprendre de quoi acheter
au cours des treize années au prêt au
début j'étais trop à l'écouté
au début un des premiers cunnilingus que
j'ai fait je vais vraiment bien faire
fonctionner trois coups de langue juste
grecque trop de langue correcte
le stade trop d' écoute c'est sous le
thème que tous peuvent cerrato que l'île
maurice qui commence à se dissiper au
lycée pays
je rejoins tonnes je te disais ma maman
cette année par le primate a juste
poussé vers sa chatte ce qui me mukendi
stand up
tout est bien qui finit bien j'ai pas
mal à faire finir mais j'ai essayé j'ai
tout à fait et c'est tant mieux
je fais ça marche c'est la seule chose
qu'on peut demander la seule chose c'est
ce qui attend parce que j'ai donné tout
ce qu'on ait des quatre maisons prises
comme ça dom la pornographie captée par
avons mûri on parler d'eux c'est
justement de cette façon là c'est ce que
j'ai dit c'est exactement ce que j'ai
dit je t'écris vraiment humaine québec
ce qui est trés de québec de vouloir
faire la pornographie un son service et
aller car oui pégase presse 15-18 bec
way le main et beaucoup de vidéos que
trois ans de pégase mais le pégase où
ils font juste l'amour dans le vieux
québec on voit souvent le ti mé on
quitterait médias sur une terrasse de
sainte foy s'est pas battu en finale le
total des gains sur l'afrique taxes ils
y font des vidéos dans le champ je pense
pause lens qu'il fallait sont fiers de
leurs couleurs
c'est xavier une compagnie pour les
graphiques vous ferez de taguer votre
charge un faux choix assez joyeux car
pas de casque sont charité à guy et ses
ridicules face à wayne magistère et nos
deux faces sur un show ça serait
extrêmement érotique mon nom mais comme
c'est ça si tu commets un léger delhi le
met en scène michel quoi que ce soit à
la fin c'est ça la fenêtre de sa phase
de sable c'est un vraie farce qui ce
tour a croisé un chat le monsieur il y
avait un haut parleur sur le top du chat
et il y avait un genre de micro ou
walkie-talkie je sais pas trop comment
il comme une quête da et il ya envoyé
chine montrent mugs c'est comme la toile
les païens son enfant et tu certaine que
c'était pas non à la vacance à la
plaquette fait quelques comportements
depuis lavallois qui soit
mais revenons à la pornographie non mais
vraiment quelle joie pour le graphite
offrirait j'offrirai les meubles
graphique que j'aimerais qu'il fasse du
coco tu fais l'amour à une femme de
vingt équipes là je serai bon à 50
mais que non mais pour être tout ça est
née d'une discussion les cachots où on
avait comme ça va commencer une
discussion autour d'eux doniphan ce qui
est un débat de société
un croyant qui est un moteur narratif
pour les podcasts ou a les jambes
d'ailleurs d'ailleurs savez on y fait
frais tanguay mon chat pour promouvoir
une france mais bref puiser qui est
quand même quelque chose moucheraud
quelques jours attirant dans le métier
d'acteur pour nous oui c'est quand même
quelque chose je me dis c'est une
activité que j'apprécie je me dis je
peux joindre l'utile à l'agréable en
tirer des revenus
c'est un job de rêve dans le fond c'est
la seule affaire c'est qu'il ya un
stigma pardon il astique mois dans la
société de saint pie mettons mes parents
peut-être que leur opinion et pas
nécessairement favorable
la seconde personne de québec dans la
soixantaine
il serait par exemple effect une
prostituée possiblement les octaves
possiblement bon mais en même temps je
vais pas leur mettre des mots dans la
bouche peut-être qui m'encouragent oui
bien qu'ils aient enfin peut-être
mercredi pour se nourrir et qui vont 0 2
face aux dalles sous-sol managua face à
nantes 1 c'est dans un vrai manque à des
professionnels et pis il faut tirer des
revenus sa passion puis mai prochain
spirale mot toi c'est le sait ça c'est
le seul frein que tout pipe à cette idée
le breizh da paix est excusé et des
parents ça veut dire que si des parents
sont encore libres un cancer voire la
peine de se faire bouffer
setc les trois phases de doyle ouais
c'était des cantons ont dit non mais
absolument pis et de la manière que je
trouverai pour combler la la peine et le
vide d'idées c'est mes parents ça sera
faire la pornographie waouh quel rôle
pour les fumées dont seraient les routes
toute une nuit
qu'est-ce que tu sois frais je ne sais
pas où tu n'irais pas ce que ça
commencerait sûrement supersoft parce
qu'au début je dis donc t'es juste juste
au pénis bandés soft est exact à max des
photos de pénis
je pense clairement demande pour ça je
l'aï fait assez rare les désirs qui sont
plus intéressants que tu ailles dans la
thématique natation c'est dans cette
vidéo on sait qu'il doit bien entendu
satisfait de la graphie la majorité sans
doute de son auditoire
il était client sont les hommes comment
tu vis avec ça surtout c'est un trou de
natation piscine mais moi je suis le
premier temps des lunettes dans les
calmes mais n'insiste pas sur son
affaire mais un site d'information et en
mettant janice hahn les traînées d'un
ici non parce que je ne sais pas parce
que je ne veux pas faire non mais tu
l'as déjà vu c'est le chauve qui est un
docteur un astronaute en fait tous les
médecins en plus de l'acteur porno je
trouve
il fait plusieurs métiers qui étaient
souvent déjà vu cette année soit acteur
caméléon
il peut jouer tous les rôles savent pas
mais lui produit ccpo vidéo le tpir sa
propre plate souliers foncés de notre
présent le soir mais fed et du contenu
avec des partenaires disney a mais je
sens moins bon le reste c'est des hommes
y consommer bien entendu annoncé des
hommes parce que on va se dire c'est
beaucoup mais tous ont fait un concours
qui peut ramasser dans une chambre tout
nu quelqu'un plus rapidement possible si
tu es venu battre de 5 1 go go on a le
droit à tout ce que sont venus dans
cette optique qu'il faudrait que dans
mon concours je fasse j'ai le droit d'en
story instagram de vingt cinq mille
personnes appareils qui vont être nue
avec moi dans un futur rapproché mais
dur mais c'est ça vous avez un plus gros
reach fait que vous avez plus de
changements mais la france j'ai
l'impression que tout homme et on sort
la porte si tu cognes aux bords des gens
et on peut se mettre nue non monsieur je
me suis pas déplacé
bonjour monsieur voulez vous mettre ces
deux options café je suis ici je prends
toujours les plus hauts du jour
je pense qu'ils contente parce que l'on
est juste content je prendrai un verre
d'eau quand on peut toujours tout le
travail que tu voies choisies les
légumes du marché plus tu dis je
proposerai un peu de jo en fonction des
cas ce qui fait que les jeux les réseaux
qui s'accomplit un peu dans son travail
de sa suggestion
j'ai une autre hypothèse suppose quand
même se mettre des choses à ta bouche
comme c'est juste un bon pour eux non
plus [ __ ] santa fe à chaque 3 50 e oui
ce que je ferai aussi c'étaient les
entrepreneurs du sexe web le nom qui
supporte des chaînes ou trop jamais leur
visage ce serait aussi gadret encore
c'était pour être envie de rien qui
m'empêche c'est pour ça que c'est un
combat constant parce que ce jeu tu peux
le faire
un couteau puis personne c'est que c'est
toi apporter ex protégé pour le gt a
tout à gagner en plus de sites actifs
sur le bras faudrait que je le cache
du cash pop c'est ce qu'ils cachent on
sait ce succès risque c'est que sa
société sicat les francs-maçons
[Rires]
international mêmes effets la vie
beaucoup de faits pas j'ai pas j'ai pas
tu penses tu ce genre nos câbles si tu
sais pas ce qu'est ce qui est plus
difficile quand tu n'as jamais jamais le
plus difficile quand tu es dans
l'industrie du sexe en tant que mâles
hétérosexuels c'est que l'argent des
clients c'est les femmes laides où des
hommes et gestes des pénis nous pour
l'instant c'est difficile car c'est vrai
je retire ce que j'ai dit pour toute la
pornographie c'est les gens possible
c'est que je connais des femmes les
femmes très jolie la regarde ce qu'ils
payent pour hommes et chacun a beaucoup
qui paye pas au basket critique parce
que ces étiquettes 7 fibrethik le
problème
en général je pense tout ce qui existe
jean-paul je viens parce que je pense
que fondamentalement une écrasante
majorité de la population qui coûte la
pornographie bhl de base l'écrasante
majorité ou à plus ou moins après 18h30
sommet tant aimé
affecté là dedans il ya de tout mais je
pense que pour tes notre ami fred lebel
en faire une taxe ou des photos ceux qui
répondent aux policiers les deux il ya
les autres travailleuses du sexe puis
les hommes les plus bizarres que j'ai
jamais rencontré
c'est bizarre commenté des fois d'autres
là c'est sûr que c'est un autre étape et
je pense pas que c'est la majorité des
gens qui fait ce genre parce que
d'hommes
j'écrivais je réponds aux répondants
pour le stuff twitter ben ouais c'est
vrai je buvais beaucoup à l'époque piste
un habitant puis moi comment arrêter de
sortir cette dépression me parler à une
borne store de californie puis crée un
lien quel critère est vrai que c'est la
pompe beaucoup discuté au caire mais
jamais fica 10 vient leur billet d'avion
mais en effectuant le fonds pour combler
ton malheur fita misère décide de créer
des liens des gens qui croyaient c'est
pas aussi profonds que c'est plus
j'avais une forte libido puis ça
m'excitait par les romains contact avec
lui très bon déjeuner jamais je crois
que c'est la force de défense c'est
qu'en période d'un accès à ces fameux
oui mais c'est sa cellule à cellule la
nuance c'est le la nuance puis on y fait
semaine encore une fois de la maison
gilles hamza à positionner la marque
positionnée parce que d'un côté je me
dis si tu es pour consommer de la
pornographie paye directement aux
oppresseurs ça va être beaucoup mieux
piles et les filles ont fait un meilleur
salaire personnes vont abuser d'elle il
ya personne qui va faire la pièce puis
de l'autre côté on dirait que la
l'exemple que ça donne le précédent
consacré pour pour mettons des jeunes
filles qui kiss qui viennent qui voient
ça comme une avenue légitime parce que
c'est une avenue légitime mais qui
voient ça comme un chemin vers devenir
millionnaire rapidement je trouve qu'il
ya celle ok moi je prends ce thème bac
j'ai de la misère est resté à me
positionner comme du monde parce que je
comprends ces deux aspects comme je le
faisais à savoir qu'est ce que je fais
que sur le sujet 1 12 18 ans c'est jeune
j'ai une amie de j'ai une amie qui qui
qui j'avais cette discussion là dans un
parc est sympathique et en
l'enseignement prime en appel a dit me
mets mes génies ils sont au courant que
ça existe ville sans parlent entre eux
comme étant une avenue possible moi j'ai
tous mes chances plus omettre la lutte
quand tu es jeune tu aimes tu es triste
chose d'adultes et m ou si elle peut
provoquer foucault mais aussi plus on en
parle mieux aussi parce que justement
plus tandis qu'une plus tu peux avoir
différents points de vue
fact peut consulter les différents
points de vue des gens qui apprécient
prendre une décision éclairée en sachant
que comme n'importe quel métier des pour
et des contres qui lobait de faut parler
d'une manière justement
nuance et surtout toutes ses faces le g2
bémol avec only france 1ère bémol c'est
que c'est c'est pour c'est pour tout le
monde que tout le monde a encore moins
leurs téléphones
mais c'est pas pour tout le monde c'est
vraiment pas demande qui est prêt à être
exceptionnel comme ça c'est pas tout le
monde minéral en un mot c'est pour tout
le monde dans l'équipe pourrait
longtemps plus le faire deuxième à faire
taire un truc été documenté ce qui est
dommage c'est qu'on défend c'est que
c'est un peu un truc pyramidale c'est à
dire que ce qu'on voit c'est les
millionnaires mais la grande majorité
plus de 90 % des filles et des gars là
dessus ne faut pas beaucoup d'argent
alors tu mets ton intimité sur internet
il ya des lic tous les talents c'est
tout le temps les quais ces photos là
son lit qui étaient des photos de toi
c'est elle sur internet pour l'éternité
pour un truc que tu le faire à 19 ans
alors je pensais peut-être 58k voilà ce
serait ce qu'un seul faux pas la raison
pourquoi la plupart des filles disent
qu'ils font de l'argent c'est que y ont
une cote
quand j'ai comprendre si je me trompe je
ferai mes excuses
mais lorsqu'une fille ou un garçon
crieront l'ifa et qui met un aspect de
côté quand à edéa charmant référencement
chapeau de quelqu un toit de large le
monde sait tout le monde se targue entre
eux on voit là un intérêt financier à
face à et comme d'hab quoi sur internet
via du mensonge et on grossit les traits
c'est être faux l'idée wifi qui font
plein d'argent mais simplement rail
portois un ben cheikh métallique heures
pour les hommes barbus les pattes
cassées 1 25 % de ses vols mais c'est
pas tous les compromis fans ce qu'ils
font la grosse pièce mais à trop grasse
et la majorité les cocons défense qui
sont ligués l'autre l'autre affaire
ausssi puis vous le savez maintenant
avec une plateforme comme pétrole non
impétueux puis à chaque 100 piasses
d'une pièce ap tuer le puits en france
et même principe dans le fond
quand même du monde qui font du cash
pour acquérir sur des transactions de
d'intimité et puis de vidéos de section
du printemps médias qui a pas de
meilleurs prix et en même temps c'est
tout à fait légitime que la plateforme
se prennent à un free de ce que nous
prouve que le frère je pense est
vraiment et quand 20% le béton le jeune
fille comme hélène boudreau qui va
falloir un million cette année bien
autrement se prendre deux cent mille 100
millions le cache un tabernacle et
descendez des emails de foi font des
montants similaires à celles sur moi mon
humble avis c'est un gigantesque temps
si bien mais gérant j'entends l'argument
de roi mais si les photos sont liquides
critiquée par les fans des gones est
issu kilic semaine j'entends certains
arguments légitimes par contre c'est sûr
et c'est la même raison que ben
attention si tu marches dans le centre
ville après 2h03 mais ça devrait être
plus les agresseurs je comprend enfin il
faut quand même être conscient de 10
dans lequel programmée le 4 mai le
piratage des deux gratuits des gros
chano de la nba se font pirater la ufc
tout sur tout et même plus non c'est une
femme de 25 30 ans que ce poème l'ifa je
me dis adultes a quand même des matières
y réfléchir cette décision leur équipe
édition prendra jamais que 18 à 18 ans
et c'est jeune pour prendre une aussi
grande décision d'abord on est médecin
quand à 18 heures
tellement la confiance de tous à moi le
danger c'est même moi pour ce que je
faisais
c'est intéressant parce qu'il ne doute
pas powell fulham aston villa mont 9 le
monde ce que j'ai écrit médecins de
cèpes savais pas je dis c'est difficile
de cerner un large parce que ça dépend
aussi des personnes et tout et tout mais
moi il ya une chose que je peux dire par
rapport à moi je suis très heureuse que
ma fille ne soit pas de kim ho là là là
là même que jean sur les comptes
facebook donné mes amis et des vieilles
photos de portes et puis des fois chaque
semaine je me dis je de free faut
enlever les photos juste pour des fois
je l'avais à laval en 2006 ouais c'est
que j'aimerais c'est oublier le
maquillage c'est au maquillage 19 ans et
quelque chose oui c'est ça tout les
boucles d'oreilles alors non seconde
était très grand ouais et c'est mon
amour je sais ce qu'on essaie de ramener
ce cadeau juste eu le temps d une grosse
pièce de boulevard et interrogeait je
les fait souvent que ça marche pour
affaires et de voilà merci oui moi ça
fait beaucoup je me sentais beaucoup
attaché les bouderies un cadeau ouais
londres et edimbourg mourir
quoi qu'est ce qui serait délicat ses
gâchettes sont à toi m'a fait parce que
je me fais des coûts de cochon la 6ème
bonne foi et blanc qui me plaît à mon
système vocal asie
[Rires]
[Musique]
il sortait avec avec un jouet dans lance
et compte de la fille ils sortent avec
une québécoise tu ne trouves la blonde
mais je pense que la fille que je pose
est ce que vous avez quitté lens et caen
mais le mail à la chine était une des
saisons s'appelle areva
mais ce thème fille qui est quiquet qui
est finalement avec hugo en jouant à
l'être
oui c'est du pasj julie dupage fait que
chaque sortie c'est quelque chose de ce
genre parce que chardy n'est qu'à
melbourne si pierre affection là bas on
a tous les médias s'étaient fait couper
la lie à la gorge la gorge pour sage
élémentaire ouais je sais que josé
théodore ouais ouais
les gens les gens comme culturellement
les gens juste des essarts avec la soeur
de véronique cloutier
mais georges encore ensemble parce que
parce qu'il y avait la cage du
culturellement c'est parce que il y
avait sur un magazine qui avait sorti
des photos de lui dans le fond d'un bar
avec paris s'il tonne
vous rappelez pas dessus il était allé
genre au mtv est allé dans un match je
pense qu'ils savaient demi ça sa
relation
sochaux est content qu'on n'a pas fait
sa fille
les gens disent ok vous souvenez vous le
dis ce qu'il veut comme on dit ce qu'on
parle de lui c'est bien qu'on parle de
paris-nice et même pas la première fois
que tu fais mais je pense que ça dit je
sais pas je sais pas cet avis est un
texte fixe ça c'est pas parce qu'on
n'est pas sous la lumière des
projecteurs qu'on fait rien non plus
s'épiler les peurs des gens sont très
bien que ça sonnait bien parce qu'elle
est porteuse et qui est bien c'est que
moi je suis bien je me dérangera pas des
feux des projecteurs que tu m'appeler
pour être sous les projecteurs depuis le
toit
les gens qui ont vraiment bien et ont
dit non à l'appel quand même parce que
je suis bien avec ça ferait du bien
d'être de plus d'un mois qui a moins
d'attention que j'ai en ce moment jamais
le système bien décrit à me dire ou es
tout et le thé le gars que jamais à ces
personnes quittent m il commence à se
reconnaître dans la marque de cigarettes
la chambre qui l'accusait qui repart
seul hyacinthe bernard lorjou réveilla
maison qui me dit elle je me suis très
correct deux fois aujourd'hui mais la
cour il sort et où puis je fais tu aimes
tu sais tu es tu comme à les accepter au
pied tu es comme jamais tout surtout vu
les vues sont hostiles à ce que les gens
te disent des choses absolument de
personnes
ce qui me paraît qu'on a ouais j'ai la
version avec moi mais je pense que
c'était un peu la vague c'est différent
parce que c'est de voir un écran comme
je crois que personne qui voit une autre
personne qui sait quelqu'un besoin d'un
commentaire oui j'adore j'adore les
commentaires youtube par guy a lepage
fait sur twitter tu le fais sur youtube
je serai jamais au niveau de bonbons et
guillaud je vais jamais dire une fois
chez violette way vendons aussi via les
supports en reste niveau là mais je suis
d'avis que de temps en temps foggia b un
imbécile pour envoyer le message de je
viens oui c'est vrai je viens en paix
prépare la guerre
c'est beau ce que tu dis assez profond
là vous avez développé un beau fanbase
le avec cooper paix avec le pakistan
mais les vagues sur la progression
comment un vieux mac ou moins la même
affaire pour le coup plus voir le nombre
de gosses sont à l'aise de me dire s'ils
peuvent toucher xtf sauce âgées plus
tout des gens qu'avant il salue tout cas
beaucoup plus rentables en bas devrait
voir plus loin et ce trio
ce qui veut dire je rêve souvent ouais
ouais ça lui coûtera coup c'est juste
[Musique]
un petit volet qui valait 20 matchs de
ce privilège le mauvais et femmes
mais oui je te dis pas plus mais oui
c'est ça on en a plein de gens qui nous
suivent fixons le fort plus il faut
parce qu'un des communautés de gens qui
aiment qui aime rire en écoutant le
podcast mourir avec nous à la bande puis
way fait que c'est vraiment très très
content au stif la révélation du monde
ait pas de casse québécois merci c'est
gentil j'aime beaucoup faire sujet du
processeur on rit si c'est comme on
vient ici puis pendant deux heures avec
du monde qu'on apprécie qu'on trouve
intéressant tout sauf accès peau s est
pas ce polo puis ben merci j'ai le
prince ici mieux il se contente aussi de
jeu par le groupe disco de les femmes en
humour tout mais je suis content que
d'être une femme drôle derrière un micro
puis que les gens que ça rebondisse
auprès de toi je trouve que tout le
monde paie de casting est quand même
assez masculin comme billet je trouve
ces remises au québec fecq trouve ça
cool de retrouver ma place là dedans
piqué avant que ce soit à l'écouté
ouais moi je dis que ça va changer de
plus en plus de femmes y as queen
pipi c'est une petite halte à convaincre
au jeu reste du projet autant pandémie
et moi le papier ce que je fais le pack
à 7 me les backstreet moi mon nom parce
que pour plusieurs raisons premièrement
faut que je m'intéresse pendant une
heure et demie à une autre personne puis
j'ai lu ça sur écoute pour tous par
soirée mais c'est vraiment of
s'intéresser à une autre personne
pendant une heure et demie pour une
écoute active s'étire la préparation
c'est beaucoup plus d'ouvragés mon pote
tu fais ce que tu sois brûlés de nantes
revu son arrêt no way me fatiguer moins
coupleux vers problème moi plus raf est
aussi je suis humoriste je voulais pas
devenir le josélito michaud de ces
tristes le pion dans un train mon
podcast c'est sûr que c'était dans un
train mais mon métier mon pote et je
veux qu'on peu de cas soit plutôt
profond mais je veux que les mais je
veux que j'avais me voir en spectacle
j'avais les deux choses je commande
savent que savent que je suis drôle du
moins montrer que je suis drôle et 2
fatigant et j'aime l'énergie a trop
mangé trop de jeu proposera l'accès que
c'est pas juste toutes ses épaules
il ya une énergie différente fait que je
m'étais dit que je vois pas de casser
qu'une femme parce que je trouvais pas
de cas ce que je préfère c'est que des
femmes puissent discuter avec tout le
temps à une femme ça c'est réglé ils se
soucient même de me démarquer homogène
fin approche
j'ai dit à steph permet de vraiment la
fille la plus drôle que je connaisse au
québec c'est moi j'ai fait t'as raison
de gens je pense dix jours tornos très
très cool c'est un bon mot c'est
vraiment vous savez il a trouvé la route
c'est déjà je répète souvent mon argent
t il beaucoup d'autres que moi
une des premières choses que je dis
ouais mais si ces choix cette saison
l'aja
je voulais pas qu'on tombe dans le bien
entendu que nous on se trouve drôle
entre nous on s'aime on est en couple
ont voté jeudi
c'est sûr qu'on se trouve bon pis drôle
à maison mais de faire sans podcast de
le traduire en podcast
traduit dans une entrevue avec quelqu'un
d'autre ait réellement drôle pour
d'autres gens et pas juste nous c'est
cela la gauche adrese beaucoup plus vert
soit plus populaire et plus de succès
que mon podcast parce que l'inversé les
magasins comme va en plus tu sais que
ton vacances ouais c'est parce que c'est
beaucoup plus drôle c'est beaucoup plus
je pense original ou des podcasts comme
le mien il y en à quoi 455 plus ou moins
dix le monsieur r plusieurs de 2,14 ou
deux personnes qui gèrent plusieurs
tandis qu elle l'énergie avec steph que
plus rare je pense que c'est la chose la
plus originale la paix terre peu plus
leur jeu très heureux aussi de faux pas
avoir un g10 podcast opi podcast par
ezag ma blonde
[Applaudissements]
vous vouliez quand même
en fait pas baser le podcast sur un
invité mais avoir des invités à tout les
épisodes parce qu'on aime et on je vois
votre dynamique
puis on dirait qu en tant qu'auditeur je
me dirais crise on dirait que des fois
j'aimerais sur le genre et mettons vous
entendre juste vous d'eux parlait de
d'un sujet théodore d'un enjeu de votre
relation aux quelque chose pige à la
façon vous interagissez ensemble mais en
tant qu'auditeur crise comme celle que
sam j'écouterai ce n'est pas parce que
je trouve que c'est mon vrai que pour
confirmer nos affaires on à l'intro
travail plus ce que je voudrais pas
entendre c est des fois un petit monde
est en garde à vue parce qu'on à l'intro
dans au début les pâturages commence
toujours par un segment où est-ce qu'on
lui fasse une ou deux chances de 5
minutes puis c'est la même principe
aussi que quand les gens disent à
l'épisode était trop court on aime
beaucoup mieux le seul ce soir que ce
soit je toujours venir après dans le
plus clément
puis même encore le savent bien qu est
ce que tu me disais tantôt le but ici
c'est de montrer que tom est drôle
on y trouvait tout se fait qu'après ce
site en veut plus si on met des billets
de spectacle une heure avec notamment le
stress et le sacré juste avant cette
demande
je pense qu'ils aient une des choses qui
fait le succès de ceux ci c'est votre
dynamique dans le fond lundi parce que
mes dents thomas comment je devais bien
ça c'est moins drôle étant une personne
original tout en corée que j'ai plus que
je suis vraiment lahoud
tu vois ses vraies couleurs quelqu'un
qui me remet à ma place et c'est ce type
qui peut dire de quoi de totalement
guéri voir piquer et steve trouve ça
absolument hilarant une fois mayol ce
même soit système tag âgées qui ont
vraiment ni les autres cas face assez
profondément niaiseux sur sa manche mais
on dirait que peu de tendresse que j'en
aurai vous pouvez parler une naissance
qui tout le temps soit drôle tu as aïeul
pis on voulait vraiment instaurer si on
voulait pas avec les mots recettes deux
fessées raconte chicane ouais j'ai pas
envie au scanner votre cas est ce que
vous chicaner envie bailly fois comme ce
soit pas plus que pour moi un modèle de
classe 15ème et sur les choses
importantes sur les incohérences
économique sur l'éducation de notre
fille
pas sûr où on va vivre pas sur nos
valeurs les trucs importants
les chicanes cvc vers seul changer de
change qui touche à l'absurde mais dont
on a été
ouais ouais c'est ça on ne t'oublie
j'étais obligé le dead comme ça youcef
touati obligé d'attirer l'attention de
tout le monde à l'épicerie cette semaine
exactement comme on nous regarde je vais
typiquement j'ai fait mon nom et la
british airways si vous ne croisez
pickeu te ment il ya un endroit dans un
commerce et que je suis 20 pieds plus
loin cette année c'est voulu cette année
on a cette année
nadine qui est la personne la plus
banale que je m'étais avec point nombre
de fois qu'on arrive à un commerce qui y
prenaient comme se prépare les épaules
je veux pas que nous remarquent un
maquillage vie les verts s'ils huit buts
et incognito le besoin s'est passé quoi
moi c'est avant la victoire des
wallabies est pourquoi je comprends
quitter puis je peux pas t'empêcher
rigole 22h25 attache ita tâche sur un
poteau dehors comment expliquer ce qui
l'attend voilà c'est tu vas redouté dans
fait qu'ils soient même nom 09/04/2010
avec gentillesse ou avec moi aujourd'hui
soit pas tout avoir
sois toi même pas que mon disque
occasions qui nous regardent
darche gaga semble au chant cachez-vous
soir promet une note dans un calepin du
monde à faire mais pas demain mais c'est
drôle parce que j'avais écouté je pense
un peu cassavettes acadie puis vous dit
que vous ressembliez extrêmement onéreux
mais valeur on est là dessus vous êtes
absolument poser mettons en termes de
quand même un homme qui gagne sa vie en
faisant que le reste du temps telle idée
comme il ya du monde sur ce thème et sa
cape de demander maintenant je pense
qu'il ya des billets plein de jeux
contradictions ses besoins c'est une
belle contradiction ce rme
mais une aussi grosse addiction c'est
j'aime tellement attention mes défauts
genre pop des fois tu as envie d'acheter
une paire de souliers weepu si c'est
différent c'est fondamental a dit ban du
monde sait que moi c'est tous les jours
même énergie
les amis des breaks d'iphone dans les
cafés pour ne déconnez pour nos
remarques et je simulink il devait le
faire la plus drôle c'était juste de
chase autres dans les allées mais la
dynamique des journées ou side a
aujourd'hui taillé comme un con
moi je me donne à fond que ça qu'on
existe existait j'existe parce que
l'autre me regarde je suis très fort il
ya peut-être aussi un temps avec à dire
qui je vivais des piments définitivement
rien tant vêtements mais ces cas dits
habillé connu de par le monde vendredi
au sénégal fait que jean lui le de la
seconde qui a fait son premier one man
show y a pas personne au québec qu'il le
reconnaît paul sans oublier ça reste un
marqueur acquis et ouais c'est ça au
québec avec lui peut-être déjà 4 6 pieds
1 avec une cicatrice dans le visage au
québec
moi on me remarque parce que tu es je
bouge la tête des gones et des lunettes
qui est un gros nez on est trois quatre
mois ouais c'est ça qui est axé lui
prend la main que sa fin est bund qui se
disent passionnés mon envie chez qui lui
fait quelque chose que poignet
quant au fait bravo c'est bon habiter
sur documentaire sur l'autisme mercure
elle ajouté galud tf1 que circuit et je
te revois ces bandits en battant san
remo
[Rires]
c'est pas ça ce n'est pas vous dire ben
ouais l'autre jour j'étais allée
j'allais courir avec ma soeur ça me fait
penser à ça à courir au sur une
plastique mais le monde ne me
reconnaissent pas mais reconnaissent
plus dans dix ou quinze sorties de
passion dans le monde me reconnaît
certes oui les échos un rythme même
parler parce qu'ils me connaissent et
moi c'est vrai parce que oui parce que
connaît pas c'est que vous connaissez je
te rend leur écran à tout les jours
pendant que si les plus brillants qui
arguaient occupation 2 puis ils vont
parler ou à celui plus brillants
vraiment le vieillard ait la même par
les confidences d'un restockage ou avec
des amis mais mais après six essais
comme estompés puis des fois ça arrive
un petit relent de comme goethe en train
de faire quelque chose qui dans ma tête
je suis plus connu le titan matadi les
personnes qui me connaît le titre
jusqu'à la même personne que j'étais
avant qu'une passion 2 bis c'est l'autre
ou même tout est resté bas est allé
dépasser laitiers comme une fille qui
pense qui me colle on était à terre à 7
en bronze comme une fille pascale picard
band take two j'oublie comme j'ai juste
pensé et écrit occupation double avec
mon pote la course ici comme je faisais
des 2 400 mètres vite avec un repos de
six fait quand même intense le puits ya
un gars qui arrêtait pas de crier déjà
avec son groupe d'amis joue sa cave et l
ap hp
oui je réponds pas je fais 1 400 jared
ans ont confisqué alice droit
d'amendement est à est têtue ph le fera
mn je m'entends une les lévites comme
puis je les dis quand même battre sur
bfm fait guillaume est arrêté après un
métier mais ma soeur est avec moi à fait
à l vote excusé je fais quand même j'ai
catherine pas ce qu'il va en voir
d'autres gens que vu à la télévision ce
ne l'est pas
il est longuement une pile les pointes
et celle à venir
il était très admiré ph des eaux des
étais débat et non mais sûrement c'est
ça sauf que là je n'ai pas porté
oui mais ses amis le savent c'est qui ce
que la leaf on est bête ou des vi
nations
ils savent qui est là où devait wichian
moi j'ai déjà souvent puis quand je
trouve que l'histoire tous ceux qui même
s'ils savent que tu exagères ok ça c'est
ce que tu racontes qu'est ce qui s'est
vraiment passé
[Musique]
ces collets c'est le film
dès que fish de tim burton ou est-ce que
c'est comme si un père qui est qui
raconte des histoires à son fils que
l'histoire tout le temps cette histoire
une simple enfin c'est comme les
funérailles tu vois tout les personnages
des histoires mais un petit peu moins
c'est juste le guide un petit peu moins
grands depuis la seule affaire c'est le
poisson est aussi gros apprentice d'où
ça vient cet amour
d'où ça vient ce désir le maire est
décidé que j'avais 4 ans puis mon
identité c'était le god save sommet est
morte fiq
je vois que les gens se m'adressait la
parole ça me rappelait mon traumatisme
dans le marché des cds je me suis dit si
je me sens d'humour ici je l'attends
l'attention d'une autre manière on veut
plus me rappeler cette chose avec
lesquels je n'avais pas démontré que les
gens les gens à parler constamment mais
bien sûr parce que je pense que c'est
peu de gens leur mère sont décédés fait
que je t'ai bien gros je trade empathie
à tous moi c'est ma mère était morte ou
à moi si mon enfant il paraît pas droit
sa mère alors moi je trouve ça difficile
je devrais pas un sens développé une
personnalité assez est aussi mon patron
est beaucoup plus se sentir les groupes
la manière d'un trou truc que j'ai
réalisé c'est que pour trouver sa place
dans un groupe si tu es très très drôle
peu importe le groupe peu importe l'âge
prépare des intérêts turgot drôles ou
une fille drôle c'était drôle trouver de
la place toi gothique que tu es un
intellectuel que tu sois un jack que tu
sois prennent au sérieux
swagger porter tout le temps quelqu'un
de drôle je peux m'intégrer à tous les
groupes ce qui commanda chez tous les
gens drôles tous les humoristes juste
les gens droit en général il s'est
décidé à tous les groupes auxquels
groupe que tout intégré et grâce à
nouveau toutes les humoristes je peux
faire maintenant un podcast
si je veux dans un gala de
n'importe quoi j'ai pu m'intégrer je
peux être comique c'est super facile
quand on a le sens du mot de t'intégrer
puis cette lecture le tue le 18 mai dont
la lecture de dressage par les banques
n'ont évidemment sont situés à travers
mais ton ta propre compréhension de soi
même ou avec certaines thérapies qui te
permet de comprendre ces enjeux là de
moi adolescent
le truc que j'ai observés chez moi c'est
que ce n'est pas le plus drôle mais
c'est celui qui s'est le plus important
est drôle c'est important pour toi tu es
sans qu'il faille être celui qui
essayait le plus fort voir plus souvent
psychanalyse est ce que je faisais
l'analyse est maintenant dans une soirée
de sa terre battue jarrett dans une
soirée plus il y ait des gags qui se
passe sur 10 à leur place quand tu
retombes chez vous de fait qui le sait
les américains disent les gens rient
plus exactement site et a pris comme ça
paraît serein ouais ok je sais quand
j'étais adolescent et jeune enfant fait
que le processus est intellectuel
presque instinctif le mot pour tout un
temps assez intéressant je pensais
vraiment intellectuelle parce que aussi
un truc que j'ai observé que j'étais
petit c'est les gens drôles j'ai aimé ce
que je me suis dit ah le bonheur qu'ils
m'apportent j'aimerais ça partout c'est
le même bonheur aux autres
pis j'aime les gens drôles donc les six
jeux de rôle sont bons même
ouais un peu plus et moins de pros
fonction vraiment à moi j'ai toujours
trouvé qu'elle l'humour c1
c'est un don de soi moi j'ai vraiment je
pense qu'on ne trouve drôle je veux
faire rire les autres
il faut que c'est une grande différence
est beaucoup de maurice qui veulent
qu'on les trouve drôle mais je suis
d'avis que je veux faire rire les autres
très différents je veux faire rire
je trouve que c'est vraiment le fun
faire rire ce territoire
ça me fait du bien il faudrait pas de
casse avec steve sachez qu'il vous fait
rire
l'important c'est pas qu'elle soit la
plus drôle que moi bien sûr je mets ce
que j'aime c'est moi je veux montrer mon
chez moi à la maison gagne j'ai
tellement drôle je vais vous la
présentez est don d'un drone à blanc
grillé avec l écouter la regarderai dont
un troll je veux vraiment faire rire et
si je me si c'est pas moi qui parle
je veux trouver moins de faire les
autres passagers autant de plaisir à
présenter des gens mon podcast présenter
des jeunes humoristes
les jeunes talents je veux faire rire
plus que je trouve trop fait qu'en bout
de ligne c'est fait des blagues avec
notamment le vac l'altitude l'attention
de ceux mais en bout de ligne c'est pas
juste pour tous actifs et si tu le fais
extrêmement oui je le fais pour moi
parce que c'est très agréable mais je
j'ai un plaisait à faire et les salue
toujours de moi c'est parce que cette
zone qui son plaisir
je vais même te donne un prêt vert a
donné réglable sépare toujours de moi si
jamais là je fais ça pour les autres
c'est pour moi mais mon plaisir à moi
c'est entendre y recevoir les gens rire
c'est voir les gens à voir les leurs
lèvres et les oreilles si voir quelqu'un
qui table sur une table ça me fait du
bien et gendarmes et on cache avec mon
ami philippe beaudry d'iron man you feel
comptes à la fin voir les gens rire l'un
des deux fils james anecdotes
incroyables d'ailleurs que ces galeux
andré qui en a tout le temps parce que
104 froidement ce qu'ils racontent très
haut c'est vraiment un bon compte en
plus qu'autre chose
moi je me sois maire à vence et
maintenant avec la mafia est ce que l
excuse pour tony faire des shows gens
faire chercher à chaque samedi où 381
serait chaque samedi autour de catherine
je fais deux shows pour ce samedi
ah oui c'est ça on arrive jusqu'au
pouvoir devant un public
mais tous les samedis je suis au top 5
4e tu fais les deux shows je suis le
seul ennemi puis celui à huit ou neuf
heures parce que le couvre feu est levé
mais je pratique mais mon stand à jj
paris sur le stand à petit pas que c'est
possible
moi je préfère dire oui pourquoi
genève est la personne toute attente est
mort on me dit je pouvais il ya des
masques et je fais attention
oui je suis tentée catherine de soirée
d'humour je suis crenca la soirée folk
commun parce que thomas lé ton
personnage on ne connaît m toi on te
connaît pioncer commenter mais comment
vous vous êtes rencontrés arriver
comment puis c'est quoi ta première
impression alors on s'est croisé un gala
des olivier puis cette année le québec
le mois ces galeux
je m'étais donné pour man 2 d'essayer de
faire un peu de pilleurs avec des
artistes plus jeunes puis plus comme des
grosses guillemets sur émergents mais
c'est que mon cher dans une boîte avec
beaucoup d'artistes établis pile pire
des fois le j'avoue que c'est pas ma
grosse tasse de thé comme la force pour
ses bons jours a pour quelqu'un qui
n'est pas sa tasse de thé du ps comme un
cauchemar
fx est quelque chose que tu as de
l'argent qu'il faut que ce soit vraiment
bon dans ces deux affaires le continent
est de même si beaucoup sont vraiment le
type pour moi c'était vraiment justement
à qui je le sais que c'est quelque chose
qui pourrait y perd naturel pour moi
fait que je veux travailler pour tout le
monde et aux quatre morts fac et puis
justement dans la dernière année je
m'étais mis à suivre d'aidé
des artistes que je connaissais moins
donc dans un humour et tout ça notamment
thomas sur facebook ça hurle par terre
c'est avant que les galères commencent
tout le monde doit aller s'asseoir et
tous puis sur facebook une plateforme
moi ce que tu mettes et joe cole et à
l'inspecteur tout cas car je voyais un
peu le personnage comme hakim ferrer et
tout est là je suis sur le parterre
avant que l'émission commence que le
galeb commence tout le monde et c'est de
s'asseoir et tous et j'accompagnais
cathie gauthier cette année là et elle
était enceinte alors tout le monde
accosté cathy parce que super bel air
une belle robe bleue est tout sauf
simple tout bravo bravo fait avancer
jusqu'à nos places étaient interminables
t on ne l'est jamais arrivé et là elle
est un peu derrière moi en train
justement jean zay dumont et oui le jeu
c'est de trouver nos places et là je le
vois je te plait messieurs qui regarde à
un complet un temps mort
jusqu'au milieu de la place au milieu
l'argent que la place à la personne au
quatrième quart de savons qu'à ce moment
le tout à l'intérieur tu étais bien ce
même mois cette histoire le lait de com
me retrouver dans un événement social
personne à qui parler au milieu a pas
trop savoir quoi regarder quoi
farouchement moi c'est cauchemardesque
c'est le goût que je suis sur facebook
que je trouve drôle je vais lui disait
salut
on est amis facebook c'est vrai que je
suis répond pas de temps à 7 ce premier
j'ai les cheveux en serait juste dire
que je trouve vraiment drôle
il est une réponse b c'est mon métier je
l'aï regardé all one way plage fait bon
mais c'est cette histoire que ça se
passe c'est un souvenir que l'horaire de
ce moment-là houba houba dans ta tête et
permanent dans la zone fait qu'est ce
qui sépare tentative c'était une
décision consciente de dire la joue et
je vois être qu'ils mangent pas encore
acquis si je peux me chose autre vie
peut-être perdu petit à petit en mode
c'est pas la personne été remis à qui je
peux parler des plus actuels je connais
point commun la groupie le nom pauletta
retard peut pas parler à une agente de
spectacle
me faut faire beaucoup d'argent qui va
dans les prochaines années la raison de
mon indépendance financière
lorsqu'une raison de parler à cette
personne que des raisons pourquoi je
prendrais stéphanie modde lac saint jean
et de marketing web suis pas drôle
aucune raison et qu'aucune raison que je
suis pas où met-on à l'assistante de
benjamin phaneuf qui peut rien apporter
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je parle tout le temps de masturbation
chic qui a vraiment fait ces familles
moi ce que j'aime c'est que du talent
puisqu'elle dumont m
mais cole se tiendra fin mai et jusqu'au
30 août au téléphone à gérer des
scandales et steph mais je savais aussi
qu'est-ce qui doit-on toi dans ton
approche il y avait la dimension
puis un nouveau dragon sergent mais
comment est ce que il y avait aussi une
dimension je trouvais mon goût puisque
le cruising pato est clair ce n'est pas
steve rien manche mais je me force à
salluit dont déjà moins que thomas topo
du saut non plus comme messi gens et qt
je veux oui non merci je posais non plus
moi mais c'était juste jeter vrai en
france au mois d'août parce qu'il faut
le mentionner avec qui tu voudrais
jamais sortir ses amis demandent si ton
cv
saguenay que des bottes casque qui parle
pas sur base sur mer m ouais c'est
toujours le regard des parrains toujours
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
s'affiche comme coincé dans l'allée
parce que lui il bouge peuple et morgane
même puisque sommes encore loin katia
larifou est il dit bonjour puis demain
soit pas fier de toi le jeu pour vivre
le moment d'y agir différemment plus en
plus de son fait que vous êtes juste
debout à côté de lui vous parlez plus
c'est elle qui sont compris dans une
conversation que personne ne veut être
demain jeudi c'est drôle j'ai dit c'est
normal c'est mon métier pour vrai
c'était la deuxième personne que chacun
croyait que ça continue ça confirmait
bonne idée que le ps actuel écrit que le
gogh parce que je n'étais pas sous
écoute où je racontais que j'avais
envoyé des photos de moi un africain qui
récusait jusque-là et que les femmes qui
auraient pu le savoir
pis c'est celle là c'était la deuxième
fois que j'accostais encore un autre
désastre
puis les gg fait c'est fini pour se
loger coûte la garder
je me suis et puis c'était quelqu'un
d'autre sur le tapis rouge au bon
endroit pour accoster quelqu'un parce
que tu prends des photos où là il ya des
journalistes puis tout le monde avance
un peu comme let's go faut avancer
fuck la personne avait été sympathiques
avec moi mais sans plus le tester pas
non plus au moins on avait changé
certaines cordialité sa vie correct mais
savait pas été comme le plus bas de
l'histoire et le jeu
et je suis même pas allé aux parités
après ashley cole cette soirée est un
cauchemar je m'en retourne chez nous oui
j'ai fini par réussir à m'asseoir qui
était venue s'asseoir avec moi galeuses
déroule depuis c'est ça allez vous
porter par les blocs de humilié a perdu
7 euros le site est auteur de l'année
pour le spectacle de mécanisme qui
aurait dit qu'ils ne gagnent pas
je me suis pris c'est pas grave c'est
dessus une fois l'amérique est il gagne
en fait qu allait gagner autant mais je
le sais bref alors voilà alors je
retourne chez moi aussi je tends
domination j'ai perdu ce wiki la plus
belle du lait fait je suis je me
rappelle ma femme et moi on s'est levés
vont pas très heureux pour rendre et
c'est un communiqué la pièce et là
quelques temps après sur vos chaussures
facebook messenger pop et c'est lui qui
juste à l'eau eska même qu'il ait jamais
la camisole ville tient pas que ça fait
tout de suite cru mais pour quelle
raison
na loba mais qu'elle était maintenant
l'assesseur moi j'ai tout de suite je
connais ce genre de gaulle a loupé le
chiffre est sûre ça c'est le genre de
gars qui devance on nous dit qu'ils
envoient des délits n'y a pas eu le
ballon à l'ol ou à l'eau puis l'ayant
pas exact faites le moi j'y réponds
allô mon ami d olivier py les rappeler
je me suis rapidement l'attitude puis je
me suis rappelé que je t'aime et
chantepie fendant et je monte mais est
ce que c'est un sentiment qui est qui
est fréquent la ou trois diamants du
souvent tomtom quitté 0 j'assume pas qui
je suis fait que je me dis j'espère
sable que tout ce qui est fait c'est
normal et les gens que cette raquette la
honte tous les jours que souvent on dit
souvent mais tu dis bien avec leur nom
du malheureux
[Musique]
olala juprelle c'était quoi le
déclenchement est ce que tu te vu une
publication de steve dans ton fils
actualité toujours penser à la fiq j'ai
trouvé très bien ce que je pensais de
paris je pensais que tu étais assise à
la terrasse de la roquette
un beau j'allais souvent jadis sur la
photo je t'ai pas à tacler thurso
finalement une réponse de ton alou moi
j'ai déjà écrit à l'eau bonhomme sourire
à une politicienne qui décorent
inspirante répondu oui mais non merci de
pas répondu à s'extraire de ce extra
[Musique]
anneaux
moi c'est ce mélange peut pas répondre
j'ai posté gaulle qui continue ton
chemin simplement je comprends bien
c'est seule la discussion aux gens un
peu ah oui ah oui on s'est croisé na na
na plus je vois que lui est vraiment
dans le mood de jarzé
mais moi josé sur les réseaux sociaux je
me base pas sur les réseaux sociaux j'ai
pas le temps je travaille je vais à
l'école et j'ai une vie et c'est comme
ça que je t'ai jusqu'à moi qui vais
jeter le fun de parler bonne soirée
j'étais tout le temps d'une soirée des
tchats devant nous l'idée soirée à avoir
cinq tables ouvertes d'entretenir cinq
concessions et en même temps pendant dix
ans
mais jorge cardoso
j'avais jamais cinq tables du verre en
même temps je garde des sceaux strict
minimum c'était pas je pensais pas de
social j'attends un professionnel savez
c'est un peu long
depuis que j'ai une copine avec le temps
jose - puis j'avais petit bémol est un
géant voulait pas du tout pour ce qui
s'était passé
bah c'est qu'en photo comme c'est cet
outil pis le bain au fil du temps lui
d'autres échanges est vraiment comme
amicaux et tout ce que man et ça s'est
transformé un sextoy ou un secteur bien
donc on avait 20 tel un black panthers
qui voit là ok ça passait de sexting
avant mettons le café avant d'aller
prendre jamais à ranger riz amical
sexting sérieux rue du gros gros sextet
fin quand on s'épuise les bourgeois au
savon réaliser tout ce temps c'est des
fois des fois du sexting c'est quand
même d'incarner un peu un personnage en
s'exposant des choses qu'ils répondent
non non non non non mais des fois
mettons le build up et qui se bat mayer
que l'accomplissement bon c'est mon
argent
le conflit s'est jamais déplaisant c'est
jamais déplaisant mais c'est pas tout à
la hauteur de la discussion
ouais c'est ça je vous dis moi ça m'est
arrivé deux fois d'avoir des séances de
texting c'est comme enquête à voir mc ça
va y aller en est-il en vrai c'est quand
même c'est fun mais c'est quand même ça
aussi qu'on avait mis la table en qui
risque en faisant à manger du pain
viande de porc ce que tu vois c'est ce
nom à la hauteur de nos attentes
est-ce que sexting était seulement un
mot où il ya des photos et vidéos
djoko c'est tout un peuple
et oui mais toi tu sois seul chez vous
mais non mais non
oui on non oui oui
ah non lui fait des messages vocaux
j'avais jamais vu ça je trouve ça
extrêmement particulier ouais mais tu
vois ça m'a quand même c'est dû au final
j'ai comme ça prend beaucoup de ça prend
aucun ego messages vocaux en line fac
est sujette à fréquenter quelqu'un qui
aimait les messages vocaux piétons
c'était comme un livre audio sexuelles
étaient sollicités c'était comme avant
je n'aurais peut-être pas fait ça
demande un message à mes clips sur le
coup c'est comme tout le monde est
vraiment content moi m'ont seulement la
stèle en un matin rassurée que ton
message
photo jj dit j'espère que le lendemain
très que de passer l'été parce que j'ai
pas dans le mode ça peut être lu ce
qu'on fait la libye dans le tapis sa
vieille très mal comme nous l'a déjà
quand est excité ce genre une espèce de
pizzas faites dans un resto italien
perdre c'est au stock est arrivé ces
gens bien pizzas congelées qui coule
nantes ont fait une belle image fait
qu'après cette impression vous actions
sembleraient très vip il est bon
on s'est mis ressorti en forme puis
voilà le vrai sens du mot qui concordent
je pense oui oui il ya plein de choses
qui me font rire qui l'ennuie et vice et
versa ouais des fois c'est maintenant
qu'on est sur nos scènes chacun sur le
sofa péter la télé joue t on un cosmos
elle est l'un des deux éclats de rire
l'enchaînement ferrer pis quand l'autre
gars d'el hadjar à quel point c'est
minable
mais même si non mais c'est vrai alors
qu'à la base je me fais beaucoup mais
mon premier mon premier kelava toi et
tes vélo c'est vrai que je le trouve
vraiment vraiment drop qui me fait
vraiment très chaud ou salle de
spectacle mais oui mais ça va c'est
documenté long de la vidéo
non mais parce qu'une dure que je sois
sur site fc vannes et je veux dire
blague avant le spectacle entre autres
je te demanderai de me lasser seul bon
ça va changer
en fait le fait n'est que ces principes
aux menaces que c'est la bonne
j'avoue que je peux travailler mes gars
comme seul dans un échange et
téléphonique avec une simple ni plus
doctes défini excessivement bien merci
non mais je comprends tu fais bien mon
médecin c'est le genre de message
continue mais c'est bon mais toi c'était
fait comment est-ce que tout parce que
là on a entendu l'histoire de
commandement est devenu
réussi à trouver pourquoi il voulait
faire du maupuy mais toi tu sais que
quoi de faire de l'humour c'est tout de
suite et tout le temps drôle faire le
mur ça tu étais option c'est parce que
j'ai été tout le temps de roland
humblement le métier je varie beaucoup
fait rire puis dans ma famille on est
tous le monde est vraiment entre conte
et d'esprit de famille très amusant la
moitié des 2 parmi les personnes les
plus drôles que je connaisse le yoyo
mais son oncle puis je sais que ça peut
sonner un peu quand même un élément
comique mais je pense qu'on est vraiment
on est une famille qui est vraiment un
beau sens de l'humour puis-je aller
développer en premier avec ces personnes
là une des personnes que j'aime le plus
faire rire c'est mon père c'est vraiment
parce que le rire le plus communicatif
cellphone astiquer kiripi comme ces deux
bons doigts de mon voile ça fait partie
de notre complicité qu'on est vraiment
tu sais ça puis quand j'étais plus jeune
j'ai fait de l'impro pied tous mes amis
j'ai fait les propos longtemps été genre
est un an à la fin du primaire puis tous
mes amitiés dans le livre de finisseur
déconne en tout cas on note que tu
deviennes hume aurait soutiré des petits
trucs comme ça mais pour moi ça jamais
c'est dire si c'est plus tard j'ai fait
du théâtre tout seul j'aime beaucoup un
peu comme tom j'aime beaucoup faire et
tout ça mais j'avais pas l'appel de la
scène où l'appel d'un artiste dans le
cadre d'une carrière parce que pour moi
n'y avait plus de points négatifs que
positifs donc gm performer tg fait du
tort musica j'ai fait beaucoup de danse
et j'aime chanter danser phare lumeau
animé c'est tous des choses que j'aime
mais justement leurs rapports avec le
public qui fait beaucoup beaucoup partie
de ce travail leur une bonne partie je
trouvais ça très dur de se servir le
pire qu est ce que tu disais tantôt le
contact avec les gens la relation avec
les gens c'est des fois je faisais des
spectacles et il y avait des gens que je
connaissais pas qui me venaient me voir
après pour me dire qu'ils avaient aimé
ce pisam samou au lieu de prendre les
conflits enfin quand même merci jeu sam
ça me confronter jeter comme tu es qui
je connais pas je trouve ça bizarre que
toi tu me connais je suis moi je te
connais ce projet tient plus comme ce
que ce tour-là sur wii
seuls les gens qui croient de connaître
tous taxés comme on dit ça fait
tellement partie beaucoup du travail
puis un autre élément que je trouvais
que ça faisait beaucoup partie du
travail s'il me ton que tu deviens
comédiens pour faire une oeuvre que
terme il faut que tu fasses des pubs de
savon à l'impro faire le chemin
c'est ça c'est pas cest c'était pas des
concessions si c'est dans la balance des
pour idc pas les concessions que je la
fais repos pour vivre cet art là mais ce
n'est pas quelque chose qui te plaît à
celle ci ça mais je peux l'instant qu'en
lot de tout mode de faire vivre les arts
de la scène à des gens ça m'intéressait
beaucoup fait qu en face à moi-même sur
la sont exactement pis le bain en
découvrant tian faisant partie d'une
troupe de théâtre et tout ça en
travaillant dans des salles de spectacle
j'ai découvert tous les autres métiers
qu'ils avaient de lier un le mythique
ont été montés tout inquiète tellement
tellement grosses équipes derrière les
gens qu'on voit sur scène c'est vrai
puis les gens ils font toutes sortes de
choses et j'ai trouvé mon chemin là
dedans pis selon les choses que j'aimais
faire piéger tison communication et le
cam moi j'ai eu beaucoup d'habileté en
informatique et/ou ce facteur a parti
demande des conseillers en com et un
travail dans les salles de spectacle
c'était aussi tout à ce moment là où est
ce que on va on commence à avoir
beaucoup plus de billets en ligne quand
personne il fallait commencer donc à
vraiment développer le marketing web et
tout donc ça j'ai fait et ça je pense
que je pourrais être bonne là dedans
puis c'est ce chemin-là que que j'ai
suivi et l'a finalement bon choc avec
tom qui finalement une humoriste et quoi
justin bieber et s'appuie comme je
disais tantôt bain à la maison on était
drôle ensemble pic a eu l'idée par un
podcast à 2 jeter comme ok mais ça je
pense que je pourrais le faire avec toi
parce que je t'aime que je me sens en
confiance puisque c'est confortable oui
je sens que justement le podcasting
c'est quelque chose qui me convient
parce que on est fait mention exemple
fac
et puis aussi à lyon il autoproduit ont
fait sauter tous et c'est vraiment fait
entièrement de même donc on contrôle ce
qu'on fait en contrôler ce qu'on dit ce
qu'on dit est ce que c'est vrai ce que
c'est pas vrai qu'on dit l'histoire
qu'on raconte son père c'est vraiment
nous qui contrôle tout ça alors ça ça me
plaît et aussi on n'a pas d'attentes de
il faut absolument que le plus populaire
possible pour que ça fonctionne alors
jusqu'à présent comme on dit aussi plus
tôt on a un super beau fanbase qui qui
aime ce qu'on fait parce qu'on fait
c'est ça nous ressemble vraiment pas
qu'ils nous aiment
je trouve qu'on a des bons et des beaufs
hans olsson et qui ont un gros groupe
facebook avec où on échange justement
avec eux puis les gens ils font des
blagues et tout ce petit jeu comme auch
j'aime notre communauté fac ça me samory
concilie justement avec ce rapport avec
le point litige comme il n'y a pas juste
du monde bizarre il peut y avoir des
femmes gentil qui disent j'aime ton
podcast merci beaucoup c'est très cool
vous écouter jusqu'à ok c'est le chu
dans une zone confortable pour
m'exprimer artistiquement flammes ouais
c'est vraiment hâte que c'est un support
vous voyez ce délai le podcast permet
justement tu sais quand tu le fais sans
compromis comme comme nous on le fait
comme vous le faites c'est à dire tout
produit qui a personne comme tu dis
qui dit quoi que ce soit sur le contenu
ça fait que les gens qui aiment ce iem
réellement ce que tu fais sans compromis
parce qu'il n'a juste pas de compromis
d'ian 9,0 fait que fait que ça fait déjà
fait des gens qui c'est ça qui c'est
plus facile d'accepter mettons là le
retour de le comprendre de l'embrasser
en fait le mec quand vous faites des
podcasts devant public est ce que tant
que cité le du public revient mais là
c'est quand les premiers on va les faire
ce samedi
mettez j'ai fait quand tu m'avais sa
soirée d'humour et pandémie un magnet
c'était le mois de son anniversaire
on a fait tous les litiges y aurait là
sur scène mais c'est ça
qu'on attende un peu déroutante au lait
j'avais eu vraiment beaucoup de plaisir
à le faire
j'ai vraiment aimé ça j'ai fait un petit
numéro de stand-up rostom la chance
qu'elle manque pas de créer un mec que
tu penses et spontex et ça m'a aussi
aidé à montceau ne collabore avec mc oui
c'est ça je travaille avec max orsato
minois qui reprend pour les billets mais
j'ai pas de vue que j'écoutais fans la
sainte gemme et ce puits pour moi c'est
pas j'ai pas de stand strike et pall
l'anxiété d'être sur cette rage une
grosse facilité à être sur scène puis
c'est souvent comme on dit le juge
je vois que meilleur devant public de
150 personnes que je connais pas que
devant me tombait par un assaut ciblant
les arrange les gg pour moi c'est
cellphone j'ai une espèce de facilité à
force de deux mille à facile parce que
la facilité a monté ça existe déjà par
rapport à que le talent corner et
d'éjection pour lui pour monter sur
scène c'est facile que nos facs et surf
excellent c'est ça aussi je donc ça pour
dire que les picasso 5 je pense que ça
va bien se passer parce que comme si je
pense je sais que les gens pensent que
je crois que les gens qui ont acheté des
billets pour encore le pour le podcast
c'est des fans qui sont ils sont ils
sont là parce qu'ils sont contents des
clubs qui sont contents de venir nous
voir
puis comme j moi j'ai quand même une
facilité à communiquer sur cinq fait le
yo comme le combo d2 c'est à dire que je
sais que ça revient qu'est-ce que j'ai
tantôt que le public qui va être le lier
là parce que il est content de nous voir
puis gpon j'ai peu cette espèce de
relation conflictuelle que je parlait
plutôt de tai chi tout et je m'étais
aussi jeudi quand je faisais de la scène
j'étais plus jeune les sudistes
j'ai aussi évolué et mature et
et à qui personnellement j'ai vécu des
choses qui monte qui monte qui monte
bâti fac je suis content je suis de
faire ce projet la plus vieille si
j'avais fait ça à 22h j'avais une femme
je leur ai peut-être à l'époque fait que
pleuvoir et que ces gars là vous mettez
ces sujets à ckoi casse gueule était
déjà rencontré non c'est plus bas coûts
cebu cours seront trop mais c'est ça je
pense aussi que personnellement je suis
rendu à un bon moment dans par rapport à
ma confiance en moi par rapport à ma
gestion de lego par rapport à qui
suis-je je pense que je suis un bon un
bon moment pour ok je pense que je suis
prête à m'exposer puis a justement dit
les fameux drjscs où les points négatifs
qui avant je savais que tu étais pas
capable déjà fait qu'un très cool puis
met donc toujours aussi thomas toujours
aussi demain puis ce furent des lignes
de son ex
je pense oui c'est ça ta lettre c'est
quand on est fatigué quand on a parlé
d'europe
et quand on a fait tous écoutent la
petite elle avait neuf mois et je quand
je revois cet épisode le je revois ma
fatigue
sa palette en design ce funeste bons
gags parler de t'choupi je fais juste
oui parce que je m'explique gaouette
annoncé cette semaine que monsieur c'est
que le gag c'était quand je les ouvre
aux tomes sur scène j'étais enceinte
puis je vois mal à rendre la job parce
que ça bref je disais match mike holmes
a toujours rêvé des noirs
ou la meilleure des mots toujours bien
vus des noix puis je pense que je veux
réaliser ce rêve là quand je vais lui
présenter notre bébé muller fait donc
l'heureuse elles sont également mitigés
alors ça c'est une vraie anecdotes mais
cela compte aussi à suzuka pour la
contre je remercie parce que le meilleur
gagne
le montoz sur internet on les comprend
un beau matin on est dans le lit et tout
le monde parle on peut dire le sillage
le mobile
génial non
un atelier de cirque dans là un beau
matin on est dans le lit puis ce que je
veux dire aux gens c'est que tout le
monde pense que tom est très cochon qui
très érotique tout le temps dans sexy
tout mais comme tout le monde il ya des
moments plus dans plus aux offres plus
tranquille peu tout le temps dans cette
mcur charge sexuelle que tu dégages
pis mais moi ça m'intéresse c'est moi
qui étais un peu comme je lai fillon
puis les grosses sommes on fait quoi le
téléphone alors mais là on discute et
oui on dit guillaume lemay thivierge et
de son école de parachutisme dessus du
tda moon s'est pas manifestée que dans
le monde si c'est comme un peu discret
mais je ne t'ai pas je prends par le
musée on se réveille bien aux gens ce
mail unis j'ai fait mais pourquoi tu
étais obsessed à ce moment le général
est stable à lui aussi un vrai dans la
vague
ce serait génial j'adore sol melia
déménager cela vous général
il ya des mecs quand je suis parti il
aménagé sur la route à grande voix avec
les bons on parle de l'école de
guillaume lemay thivierge pleut je fais
je mélange va susciter la discussion et
le jeu mais je me colle je me penche à
ce que tu veux que je te soutiens comme
il ya comme j'attends aussi un peu juste
comme il ya de l espèce de feuilles d'or
discussions puisque je ne sais pas tu
sais pas si tu fais des discussions plus
je vais manquer c'est là que je
manifeste mon switch le mood et il me
répondait ni très fier je suis non je
continue à parler de mire les médecins
[Applaudissements]
c'est incroyable c'est fun on a parlé
des clients ça finit par catchy que
c'est quand même intéressant comme
suggestion
non mais j'aimerais ça qu'on continue
d'au revoir on a commencé quelque chose
on va aller à l'eau la mort n'est pas
morte je crois juste sexuelle gd un de
mes auteurs préférés préféré s'appelle
alessandro baricco puis lui sa force
c'est dans les dialogues
les personnages vont dire des affaires
qui sont vraiment on dirait que chacun
des personnages mener une trame
narrative dans sa propre tahiti avec
vous comme se parler un peu ça vraiment
connecté connectés ou sans vraiment
s'écouter bien et qu'il veut passer un
moment qui va justin c'est les deux la
perse
une des personnes pensent à être dans un
moment vivre un moment quelqu'un d'autre
mais l'autre personne dans sa tête
or juste continuer son chemin qui veut
juste dire une phrase complètement hors
de contexte pas du tout en lien avec
leur maman
c'est un peu comme les personnages de
baricco 2c et 2d
mais pendant combien de temps tu peux
parler de l'école de parachutisme
guillon le début il y avait eu 10 à
l'humiliation impôts et qui n'ont pas
tout et quand je dis ça existe et je
vais pas changer suis pas contre l'école
de parachutisme pas je peux reprocher
compter qu'elle existe juste discuter et
sous quel angle je pense que ça avait
partie parce qu'il y avait eu son
intervention au podcast de bellefeuille
cse c'est que guillaume lemay thivierge
été invité au podcast de françois
bellefeuille sur l'environnement je
pense que ce sont un peu comme ballon
convoité vol des avions sur le fait qu'
une démarche écologique derrière je
parlais je pense à cette démarche
écologique
derrière l'école de parachutisme guillon
ne tue vierge qui est 31 c'est très
intéressant
on veut tout et bains où j'ai envie de
continuer
pied ferme et 50 ans baptiste qui
prépare son boeuf le 14 mai c'est
fascinant commencent les cerveaux
peuvent fonctionner différemment
ça m'a toujours vraiment impressionné le
mais j'ai toujours été quand même assez
cartésienne le moment c'est rock que je
m'égare mettons dans ma tête j'étais sûr
que quand je rencontre quelqu'un qui est
capable de ces gars insight laisse en
face in commenté lee c'est vraiment des
connexions dans le fond c'est
impressionnant moi je pense que c'était
fait moi c'est ça je m'égare
il était plus jeune et qui plus est je
suis d'avis que je suis très analytique
mais mes amis sur niaiseuse c'est que ça
c'est indéfendable et peut s'écrouler
ce petit coup de pub ça tombe tel appel
qu on a passé un podcast complet ou
presque
haas a argumenté sur le film de joe
kaeser a bien vieilli radio que ce super
film toujours que c'est les plus menacés
par la cij sur twitter une photo du
joker je vais attendre enviable
on se raconte dans un pacte plainte dit
que je veux entendre plus moi ce que je
disais en plus c'est que parasite
c'était meilleur le score ton bac es
dans ton équipe et le public
[Rires]
le joker le la dernière est celle où
sans fil
j'en ai parlé de joe cocker fait le
petit royaume qui viennent de faire mais
c'est comme le le le
ce pauvre ilan ramon tué gueule du monde
masqué parce qu'il te reste un joker
john lennon et paul pierce geogirl a
financé le film il retient deux
acrobates plus et des bombes et les deux
excellents mime ya dessus y avait
d'autres sujets parce que sa liste au
nom non seulement parler mais pas choisi
mais oui carla bruni excentré fabregas
avait que deux femmes qui ont un podcast
qui parle de dating parler de qui paie
la facture qui paie la facture ont petit
à petit si tu l'homme qui pulse la femme
moi j'ai nagé une hypothèse là dessus si
on est tout entière parce que ça aussi
ça le salut des commentaires sur et
autour de tout l'état est sourd ce
podcast les gueules genre j'ai un
conseil c'est comme amener votre dette
au team event en reste au moins une
femme tout je sais qui a fait 9 km dans
un truc avec la grille à 17 ans dans le
réseau
non donc toc toc toc
si c'est un nom très bon sinon qu'est
sûr que l'idée d'amener quelqu'un au
starbucks mettant moelleux des dettes
café oui ça m'arrive quand même
fréquemment hockey fait team je
comprends que tim une certaine
connotation au team de commerce à vos
team dystopie chip le titre ultime non
je suis maintenant tu vas au team en
charge tu fais comme dans le topic sur
est d'argent petits boutons café si si
c'est ça c'est mal
voilà des faits de laval la taille du xi
check and co à vis de qui ce qui en fait
c'est qu'ils sont allés chacun que leurs
chars oui dans un parking en descente et
leurs fenêtres et on verra s'il est
aussi font ça se vend entre les autres
joueurs dont les histoires de rejet pas
si fort c'est police juste de wire puis
je pense que c'est la vie mais c'est
possible mais mais mais effectivement
qui en fait toute cette discussion les
basée sur le fait qu'une première dead
c'est normal d'aller où arrivent tout ça
coûte 200 toiles à ce jeu jusqu'au bout
ça m'est jamais arrivé monde analyse qui
paye à une première deit le plus laid
c'est le plus l'équipe est élargie pour
ce haut lieu
vous avez des habitants qu entraîneur
c'est que tu avais lorsque vous êtes
tous beaux fait que vous comprenez pas
que quelqu'un paye pas mal de fautes
restaurant parce que vous êtes déjà
magnifique et ça c'est le cas avec vous
c'est un privilège bois aucune dit c'est
quoi ça magna qui avaient créé du jeu
mais pas sa laine cardée crazy j'ai
compris très rapidement pour ce boxeur
mais ça c'est le fun car ici on le sait
qu'il est plus les cartes foresta
membres le nom toutes les fois que je
vais souper avec c'est fou manger et
step et portera pop
ce tout le temps mon gars facture
certains font ils savent alors oui je
dois surtout les femmes et je sais pas
c'était au courant avec tout ça j'ai pas
ça de l'argent mais c'est ok avec toi
voilà c'est le plus laid c'est ma
théorie par contre ux arras encore plus
encore quand vient le temps des
personnes la presse attendait le plan
sur toi pour avancer
la fin même vers toi mais maintient
comme on demande au cerveau au contraire
si tu sais jouer tes cartes
c'est très cochon mais moi je suis
d'avis que c'est sur le plus l'équipe
que tu prends la facture mais ça veut
dire ces trucs hyper lebel bah oui vous
savez ça revient ce cochon c'est pas une
question de menacer un type de peau de
monsieur mais ça peut être sympa aussi
que d'accepter son rôle de subalterne
fait en contre parce que ça dépend de
comment tu vois donc ya pas de bonne ou
de mauvaise réponse parce que ça dépend
vraiment des faits mais c'est pour ça
que se pose pour ce que c est compliqué
complexe jamais le régime dans ma vie
j'étais d'une chance inouïe
j'aime l'argent entre la chambre je
voudrais quoi et comme et ses dents
parce que quand on parlait de ces
chemins sont indécis j'ai déjà facture
pour justement la bonbonne podcast moi
j'ai dit mon point de vue c'est ce qui
me fait ce qui me ferait le plus jeune
est utilisé de façon des bandes est le
même c'est de justement on parie que ça
devienne un des beaux parents cauchemar
thomson je les ai déjà il ya déjà des
gens dans la vie yem débattent de toupie
au fond des choses c'est ce qu'ils
aiment et ils veulent une personne qui
va nous font des choses la pire depuis
les relations amoureuses c'est quand on
veut vraiment quelque chose que l'on ne
veut pas que des gens aiment ça
donc la première des avoirs la
discussion dès qu'ils devraient payer
sur une première date hypothétique en
général de le parler de ce mois ça
m'ennuierait profondément aux besoins
des bouquins qu'on est très passionnant
ouais moi sauf qu'il appréciait beaucoup
ensemble non plus et c'est différent la
création est un peu l'idée de lui l'idée
derrière ce que ces genres de la
conversation et de me diriger vers
l'issue de la soirée
certaines séquences c'est comme tout
arrive on a quelqu'un qu'on connaît
vraiment rester vague lemay qui qui
commence une aide en vie avec toi mais
ton juste comme tout et fétiche le cqn
nico et oui mais nikolay sac à main
c'est frontal été séquencé rappelé
tisser s'effectue ce coach juste comme
ça ça n'a aucun lien avec ce qu'on a
peut-être là ou non l'intention de
franchir seul sur scène - sécurisation
de la première des way édition du fifem
sexuellement tous extrêmement 5 comme
discussion est très cochon
je ne sais pas mais c'est ma
personnalité je suis d'avis je me rend
intéressant ces discussions le sait que
c'est super important
avoir quelqu'un qui te connectes sur ses
valeurs et l'important c'est pas qu'ils
paient occuper un poste que la
conversation soit le niveau
voilà c'est sophie c'est que vous
rendiez sur ce voile ah ouais c'est ce
qui te trouver quelqu'un avec qui mais
ça c'est une version son c'est une
valeur trop importante si tu veux dire
si tu t'entends pas que l'argent bonne
charge mais l'argent parce que c'est pas
nécessairement l'argent c'est ce qu'on
se plaît pas large et 1 - moi quand je
les aborde
je dis oui ça me oui ça me dérangerait
mettons dans un monde où est ce que je
bosse 300 pierres sur un super puis que
trop ça c'est beaucoup le même temps que
je bosse de santé sur un super puis
quand on se revoit pas mes tantes et
monétaires maj je ferais comment c'est
plate mais je ne suis pas un an je le
sais l'enjeu serait vraiment plus dans
de l'ordre de on s'entend pas sur ce
béton sur cette dynamique la quittance
clic est toujours dans narnia d'être
comme c'est comme c'était quoi ta vision
un truc rôle des grands hommes femmes
c'est quoi ta vision c'est différent
c'est dommage construiront intéressant
de payer la facture
toi qui en disait long sur la manière
dont de voir comment s'est passée la
dette ou tout autre volet relation
amoureuse
je t'explique si cela va des dettes à
achever pays qu'il a fait est fait
ah non moi ce timothy j'ai vite compris
à votre épée au rvr moitié moitié
l'artiste et noir je te dois rien qui on
s'envoie plus c'est qu'avec
moitié-moitié c'est important pour moi
soit quand j'ai un truc le plus sexy par
contre entendu ça je paye à mais mettons
ça te rend cochon de ce mémo dommage
pour déjeuner ou prochaine fois je paye
moi je paye la facture super de voir
alors qu'il sait qu'on s'en va avec ce
plus que le féministe comment tu te sens
par rapport à l'égalité des sexes c'est
bon comme ça je vois c'est une question
de poursuivre là où les filles ont su
ouvrir lui-même 10 a déjà regretté
non c'est moi qui paye j'ai eu tellement
de fun mais c'est une très bonne analyse
à laquelle j'avais pas pensé mais
effectivement qui souvent qu'à ta télé
car ça fait plusieurs dettes au lieu
d'expliquer à chaque fois c'est comme un
peu chacun son autopsie comme juste plus
simple comme ça mais la file sur la
première dès tous et pau mais j'avoue
qu'elle prendre les risques déjà plus
rare du fun je vois pas la facture puis
aussi dans un premier à deit c'est un
objectif c'est d'avoir des rapports
sexuels avec vos personnes tout est
sujet donné cochon tout et j'ai envoyé
de ricine de j'ai envie de toi y compris
qu'ils payent compris qui paye ma tant
que femme forte que moi je suis mordu de
course
on fait payer des verres que sedan aussi
eu un bol du bo bo mais ouais c'est ça
c'est que des fois tu sais que j'étais
assise au bar avec une de mes amies puis
la fébrilité pas nous envoyer des vrais
de moussu mais le mousseux était pas bon
ça arrête
c'est cette richesse premièrement à
wright parce que ce ponot de mou depuis
merci beaucoup mais son montant dépasse
même façon mais là en plus le breuvage
était pas mais c'est l'homme qui insiste
pour payer maintenant et il y avait des
lunettes soleil à l'intérieur au monde à
crozon miroir oh ouais je connais parce
que ce sont eux qui ne s'étaient plus
anciens bull pas mon dieu nico s'il te
plaît trouve ce commentaire
maintenant est ce qu il ya de la nuance
dans vos commentaires
pas celle là c'est le chic du thabor
je donne mon avis le sur internet c'est
ce que pourrait susciter nos auditeurs
ners notre podcast fait insulter nos
hôtes comme ça c'est super
c 'est pas casse les plus controversées
qu'on l'a fait avec toi ouais mais on
n'a rien on a fait un bon side are we
feel it is f méthyle mam est extrêmement
écouter en audio et on peut tenir ce
niveau c'est des gens ne cherchent pas
carrément la vague comme ça sans fil
puis les côtes des bois la femme qui
crie sur le joker puis sur la
pornographie alcool en oeuvre audio
un podcast retrouver le commentaire il
va le trouver les beaucoup de
commentaires ce podcast effet un
contrôle f top teams
mais c'est vrai que d'aller chercher un
café n'avons que peu importe non c'est
ce pédalier marche et ont cassé les
cafés maintenant le café ccc ce qu'est
qu'ils viennent trouver de l'aide on
vient de briser la solution mais là on
utilise ce que toi tu dis que c'est à
dire tu payes pour une personne pilot
personne dit je dois payer à prêter mais
pourquoi met-on payer là un café c'est
parfait parce que prochain récents fou
c'est juste c'est facile de mettre sur
le dos de ça va être plus simple si
shore une carte qu'on paie une fois la
pression l'autre personne va répondre à
la prochaine fois c'est moi qui le tue
bien particulière celle de aussitôt
little bird et devant ça coûte pas trop
soudainement starbucks s'est rendu le
truc que la pelouse claude nicaud et
vous trouvez dans les commentaires moi
je les sens il écoute les gueux une
première des taux reste au sein temps je
suggère toujours pour la première de
starbucks ou tim hortons proviennent
chic abordable est apprécié au pire tu
vaux superbe
si jamais tu as pris en otage c'est pas
parce que c'est une corporation
oui oui américaine pourtant on tombe
repas dans un des bosses avec eux
petit il ya une issue j'ai tant
qu'héritière en exactement la voix
l'issue pas juste - tout cela est ce que
est ce que vous pensez qu'avec le
déconfinement puis le retour des
spectacles ce que vous pensez que le
podcast pour vous c'est devenu la chose
qui va pas bouger
même s'il ya plus de show qui se donne
même si vous mettez votre temps un peu
plus dans des one man show dans plus de
deux- gai gai avec des artistes etc
est-ce que vous pensez que le podcast sa
devise ça reste la partie prenante de ce
que vous allez faire à part cela parce
qu'on s'entend que avec la crise avec le
confinement pour la fin des salles de
spectacle devenu vraiment une
alternative super intéressante ce que
vous pensez que ça va rester pour vous
pour l'instant oui pour l'instant une
question si bas de caisse continue
c'est pourquoi si je fais des spectacles
si on est encore en couple la question
c'est est ce que tu as commencé dessus
voici étape et c'est mal
très drôle c'est sûr c'est pas ça mais
le couple voire une semaine
[Rires]
je me plains jamais ma farc est fou je
m'en fous je fais est ce qu à notre
podcast avec mounir j'ai vu une crise on
exagère puis j'ai ri de jean marie
lapointe c'est le fils de jean lapointe
est un homme qui est très musclé qui ait
beaucoup les gens dans le besoin a dit m
stuff ya pas épatant 10/11 steph l' on
s'écoutait message arrive et on s'essuie
j mutuellement sur twitter pillages et
s'écrie j'en remercie de me suivre sur
tout le temps c'est du roman en avant à
45 t comptable et suivent les comics et
que baisse à d'autres
lebron james à l'hébreu
l'échantillonnage mais jusqu al aqsa
pour sa belle brune de la pala privée
avec ma crise était restée mais non mais
non mais non mais je venais pas déplacé
il étayait dit merci et ses ip fait que
je peux y est tellement bon donc je peux
même pas l'ail est parfait non mais rien
de mal à écrire au tableau la bonne
musique
non mais je les regarde en ce moment j j
appelais j'ai aucune idée quoi penser de
la descente
tiens je ne sais pas c'est qu'ils gulch
part d'une crise d'asthme ou non j'avais
[Musique]
5 ans jeanne ne pas manger de tanger
parlement écrit à plein de stef de
manière respectueuse mais il fait trois
premiers oui oui oui les 7 5% sais pas
ce qui est créé à table en mai je suis
là pour faire tâche très heureux ne
savait pas que sa table handisport de
plus flatteur que que des gars qui
veulent rentrer en contact avec table on
comprend tout premier décrit chaque
c'est l'intervention je bois pas
d'alcool
juste des fois n'ai-je pas plus mais je
prends pas mon chat au tout premier
olala n'ont pas répondu
j'ai répondu jean ray avec plaisir ou au
plaisir je me suis plus le jusqu'à huit
ans parce que l'addition c'est donc le
temps je me mets moi je savais pas qu'il
était beau dans le groupe est déjà
compilé faut tout le symbole un enfant à
cause des gens comme tout homme on peut
plus écrire en privé à une personne sans
que ça soit la honte la honte tu rigoles
il regrette maintenant avoir écrit un
staff pour quelque chose va se passer et
sait même pas quel point on n'a pas
offert de nuit beaucoup de temps pour
l'accord qui aux dettes repos tant les
pauvres que ceux ci aient des six
consacré autant de temps à aider les
pauvres cas sur ses traces sur ces
trapèze
il y aurait plus rejoints
y'en aurait pu ces frais misé mal le
jury commentaires exploit juste rappeler
aux gens qu'ils écoutent de tout prend
ce que tu es maudit ou 2e degré qui fait
des blagues et plus n'est pas au fait
moins de squats
oui a dit mme fatiha khl annonce un vol
à voile à cette fois là on fera pas
l'air on va le dire en introduction des
personnages à la maison est ce qui est
identique y est pauvre et oui mais tout
n'est fait contre moi mais oui mais
souvent c'est une réaction de deux des
gens qui sont comme au shit et mes amis
y compris steph je tape sévère tous mes
amis proches mérité pétionnaires au
début oui mon fait trois au jardin
promet bat avec thomas parce que quand
on pense que c'est un personnage qui
fait de toutes les personnalités qui
auraient pu choisir ces sectes et
pilleurs fonds à ça il ya des idées
derrière c'est de l'amour derrière ça a
on pensait que c'est juste une manière
d'agir pour mais ça me plairait aussi
des fois t'es comme couple ouvert on le
dit ouvertement que c'est un podcast
humoriste et puis ça me fait rire quand
les gens prennent au pied de la lettre
vraiment ce qu'on ce qu'ont ils dit si
on n'aimait pas d'opinion est très
intense puis quand on discute de choses
c'est pas parce que on a la science
infuse qui on est vraiment à 609 était
avec une géo cormier on avait eu un 10
minutes sur le fait que l'état tout donc
c'est une manière d'exprimer son
homosexualité est à nostalgie
j dans la marine way beaucoup de gens
ont commenté ça manque de nuances mais
pour nous ça fait rire aussi seul parce
que je pense aussi que dans une espèce
de climat sur les réseaux sociaux en ce
moment que tous les gens dont 13 à 6
heures une opinion plus ils vont la
défendre bec et ongles jusqu'à la fin
alors que nous tout est prétexte au
moins une personne a sur moi qui écris
twittos m'agace c'est fait pour les
ponts oui mais c'est ça chauffe un peu
mais sont pauvres et les possesseurs de
la bare bones en france ont été attaqués
mais j'y croise mon attaque des bois
comme ils savent xx tarija qu'est ce que
j'ai en ce moment c'est que ce que tu
dis là au sujet du team de starbucks
monsieur si on en rit un peu c'est
vraiment pas grave tu es ça enlève c'est
pas c'est pas la fin du monde politique
à la chambre des communes ont détruit
points et puis en plus c est ce que la
base aussi c'est un argument auquel
benoît hamon
c'est une suggestion amical puis là on
s'en amuse un peu chiche aucun défaut si
on oublie qu il ya des choses qui
peuvent ne pas être pris au pied de la
lettre qu on peut comme disent les
jeunes dabi oui évidemment et notes
d'épicés c'est des fois ça me fait rire
que c'est à coup plus voire choqué de
toute évidence là on passe d'une gueule
on est un couple qui est beaucoup plus
voir beaucoup plus de postes une job
c'est la discussion qu'on a eue
justement avec les deux avec julien
année et 4,6 le train c'était juste au
final c'est juste une discussion ans
quand le jugement qu'on a fait c'est
jaser dont leurs opinions et leurs
visions du truc qu'on leur expérience on
a là un autre on en discute
c'est peu refait pas le monde c'est pas
plus plus plus dit que sedan sens getty
ci après parce que les gens l'écoutent
métailié les gens qui venaient justement
commenté pierre augmenté puis avec des
paragraphes de deux axes pourquoi ce
discours le hand féminin comme hostile
pas d'accord on n'était pas d'accord
mais genre
après si c'est comme avec ce téléphone
merci piano celle d'un tipi et retail
que nous aussi notre rôle c'est pas
prendre ces commentaires lors c'est pas
sérieux
mais les commentaires aussi peut-être
des fois c'est pau c'est sérieux c'est à
dire la majorité du temps et montmagny
et on l'avait reçue une personne
transgenre sur le podcast puis il ya
quelqu'un qui m'avait dit parce que
piste à l'anneau premier podcast que
j'étais plus nerveux plus j'avais des
tic des personnes nerveux suscité des
critiques avaient commenté j'aurais
clairement dom et transphobes on le voit
dans la main mais genre pileux j'avais
répondu permet de réaffecter marzouk a
fait en aiguille je comprenais qu'il
faut pour tenir ses promesses et crème
la personne qui dit tout un mot question
pour les pauvres bêtes à deux canadiens
et la déconne ouais c'est en ce sens que
même les gens excuse moi même les gens
qui déconne pas même les commentaires de
personnes qui déconne pas qu'ils font
jusqu'à dire quelque chose qui y lit mal
la conversation comme justement
quelqu'un qui commença par une étude de
féministes sur la conversation qu'on a
eu peut-être alors que clairement la
décision des feuilles de poster le bild
pas nécessairement antiféministe c'est
jovetic [ __ ] de voir suffit de lire
puis que ce qu'il faut entendre au chic
c'est quelque chose qu'il faut que je
travaille tient en tant que moi qui
crissent contenu l'oeuvre qui le maire
dira je ne peux pas commencer à avoir ce
commentaire leurs pieds a pensé qu' à
chaque seconde qui est un commentaire de
même falloir que j'embarque dans un
débat sociétaires sur des enjeux
d'égalité c'est comme manon tabarnak
long une conversation ont des enfants on
en dit on parle d'eux on parle quatre
heures par semaine sur un podcast hippie
fait que je n'ai pas me laisser affecter
par se lasser il ya une fois on avait
reçus mais c'est plus un courriel ou un
commentaire qui n'exige à quand vous
avez dit ce style zen ou si pour ce
pilote est en expliquant pourquoi
puis je me suis tu étais comme l'aurait
qu'est-ce qu'on fait accès le nom mais
parce que les e-mails et l
des genres c'est ultra longue c'était
rempli de faussetés qu'est ce qu'on fait
on répond que si on fait que je fais
bien
free expert en fait rien non mais on
fait rien mais c'est juste que c'est
parce que sinon on prendre plus jamais
la parole moi je souhaite parce que bien
entendu lequel comme tu dis dans un
podcast dans un podcast humoristique ou
un peu plus un peu plus de discussions
comme vous mais sinon votre toujours
avoir peur de dire quelque chose parce
que je sais pas si nuancé
parce que ça a été interprété de cette
façon et ce en mettant oui c'est super
important d'avoir un disque où est-ce
qu'on est conscientisé attention faux
pas des mots seulement sur internet
librement quand ça fonctionne internet
c'est que les gens doivent commenter ces
seuls médias
celles ci ont le droit puis même même
moi qui tiens des bossus sa publication
la limite tu t'es content jeux comme
gears notre contenu créé des réactions
avec une soupe ce à ce petit à petit et
c'est positif le tir les cuirs
commentaire la femme de ben amor qui
aiment le contenu militaire d'alisa de
personnes s'est rendue jusque ici dans
le podcast a commenté exactement ce que
tu me vient dire dans les commentaires
ça va me permettre de pousser sur
l'algorithme commenter ces bobos gueule
mais aussi j'ai fait l'expérience
c'est comme ça que j'ai eu à manger que
je fais de l'autogestion de commentaires
sur youtube
j'encourage les gens dire n'importe quoi
certes la couleur favorite
un film que tu as aimé si ta couleur de
cheveux que tu aimerais avoir comme ça
ça fait coucou super algorithme a b c d
e f
je pense que si tout le monde est relax
que des comores et à bahrein opinion
à l'aller les arguments forts avec du
plaisir
[Musique]
les courriels aussi qu'on soit qui lui
dit qu'on est misogyne je lis par et
puis je dire si la critique de la juge
balade gaza je suis vraiment ouvert aux
commentaires des des fois précieux
l'argumentaire où c'est utile c'est
comme si je peux toujours d'accord de
foot en accord leur parle encore métier
je lis tout cas on y vend tout paraît
vraiment pas fier mais c'est aussi ce
contrat phare mais mais c'est pas besoin
d'à quel point ça vous arrive maintenant
le nombre de tes maintenant des gens
fassent courir dans les commentaires moi
ce que je trouve le plus particulier
surtout dans le cas précisément d'un
humoriste l'été je ramène ça aussi au
fait que nous le paca c'est vraiment
plus à connotation humoristique tome sur
sa page facebook sur ces réseaux sociaux
c'est un humoriste
j'trouve ça particulier quand une blague
est prise pour amorcer un argumentaire
sociologiquement parce qu'une blague la
nature d'une blague c'est exagéré c'est
une caricature c'est on dit souvent
c'est comme si un quinqua qataris qs
parce que le nez et c'est trop gros
c'est ça
si ce n'est qu'après ce wind up et
racistes peuvent être misogynes et tout
ça mais je trouve ce particulier des
fois quand il ya quelque chose que il ya
une amplification pis que le à vous êtes
contre les gays ok je ne pense pas que
le gag qui souligne ont souvent des
hommes hétérosexuels qui nous disent
mais la majorité de la plupart ont mené
par des des gens qui m'ont dit que c'est
un esti d'hommes blancs 6 cd un blanc 6
la plupart des hommes qui montrent des
visages était pas déjà un visage étaient
des hommes
[Musique]
ces bouchons la plupart des critiques
violentes vient doit avoir aussi un haut
pourcentage d'hommes qui consomment sur
you tube we sur instagram du second pour
ça en fait j'y mets sur instagram 50%
c'est beaucoup parce que l'application
est faite 115,5 ouais c'est à 50% en
donne un drôle de phénomène de ce fut ce
qui pour d'autres dans ce sens l'esl a
décidé sa liseuse ou non mais plutôt que
des cités de puces qui est en même temps
tu peux aussi dire et moi de ce que je
vois je trouve que c'est un mot fois
vous raciste et tout ça c'est juste que
des fois je trouve ça choquant et
s'étoffe avec lui moulent comme j oui de
toute évidence et des jo qui peuvent
vraiment inapproprié
mais c'est des fois tu peux dans
l'interprétation
de partir dans des gros discours
argumentaire et tout ça des fois je suis
juste comme c'est si tu fais un gros
contre argumentaire si je dis mon mon
gars que ce n'est pas un argument
je n'ai pas en train de prendre position
sur un groupe de mode présente ses
positions ce qui dit comme des arguments
en réalité des blagues grasses mais je
pense que j'écris lui rien que je mets
sur facebook que je pense par exemple
exemple hier j'ai dit en blaguant que si
on perdait le 15e auriacombe son auto je
vais repartir les faits le cul ouais
juste une blague je veux vraiment gang
reygadas ok je veux pas partir un groupe
terroriste pour la souveraineté du
québec
voilà tu veux vraiment gagner voilà je
pense tout ce que je dis mais la figure
de style et pas nécessairement là mais
je d'accord avec toi qui s'est attaché
pour l'humour mais c'est aussi coaché
pour les non juristes dans ce sens qu'il
ya plein d'affaires qu'ils disent sur
des podcasts d'humour que ceux-ci
molette est prononcée sur le sans fil
podcast par exemple ça serait la fin
mais dans la vie il change de contexte
l'accord pour être chic avec beaucoup
sur facebook que ça fait longtemps que
je l'assumé je le fais même puisque
facebook
quant à wells que c'était une femme
disait ça ne passera pas ou bref le
temps c'est moi qui le dit gaulliste
si tu prends ce que je dis tu mets la
bouche d'un autre tout change des mots
de compagnie voilà le contexte est
extrêmement important non mais dans ce
sens nouveautés on fait des blagues des
fois on est aussi des fois mes défauts
vraiment pas échappé une fois dit biot
l'école sont a fait savoir des foules
ccm est ce que tu vas faire là pointe
sur une femme ou pas vous serez jamais
c'était sérieux pour voir ça n'est pas
de la santé
je me dis aussi comme créant des fois le
lait il ya des gens qui manquent
mais qui manque d eau chaude et j'en
passe et des périodes parce que moi ça
m'arrive souvent tu tombes des pièges
l'appui de manquer d'humour
puis on m'explique que je manque
d'humour on tombe tout dans six mois je
tombe sur ce point la france me revient
souvent en tête et que je me dise et
imagine toujours prendre au pied de la
lettre
tout ce que tu entends et tout ce que
j'ai besoin d oui jamais langue mais
comme c'est bien entendu si tu prend au
pied de la lettre
mais tout est à jeter haute et extraits
j'ai vu le vrai changement commençaient
à dire n'importe quoi tout le juste
milieu mais bien entendu que des lignes
a pas franche et bien entendu que des
propos que c'est vraiment vraiment pas
correctement mais la presse il ya
vraiment une grosse zone où est ce que
ouf
imagine les unions qu'ossa donne mes
brouillons les signaux que ça donne ça
pour des congés d'hiver truc génial dans
un forum
c'était story c'est une femme qui se
plaignait que la pub puis les
commentaires de belles hausses la pub
c'est pas mal c'est la nature du
truffaut halal forme où effectivement
c'est hachette un chalet de ronaldo tu
sois pas être bon comme ronaldo dans la
douceur et merci beaucoup je plaisais à
vue ne le parle et qui fera de votre
carte par semaine c'est l'fun
c'est la dope ça vous vous accélérez
d'enfants tout c'est ce que ce fait de
pratiquer ces deux-là job c'est de la
durée fait pas un enfant gaie ouais ben
je t'aimerai ça aussi enfin enfin on va
retourner
normal c'est quand même la diable la
prep c'est tout ce que tu dis tantôt bon
un podcast le fait deux fois le booking
système mais c'est nourrissant aquiris
par exemple je me sens pas nourris merci
aux parents de nous à hadji avec tout le
christ c'était oui mais parce que parce
qu'on le pense le mieux c'est extra
c'est pas de casillas et pas de casque
lui je trouve que c'est une grande
grande est la maxime tout ce qui fait
les grands
maxime j'avais un énorme mental c'est
maxime gervais s'il vous plaît à lécluse
la musique fait des albums c'est très
très bon maxime gervais tout artiste
unique au théâtre nico n'est que juste
mentionné eux
merci qui a su embellie même chose un
jour
merci ouais il prend de la confiance
mais de twitter verte corpo
oui il ya des raisons croyants mais
l'iran du nickel
il serait il fait partie de la famille
de l'essence mais je me caresse tokyo
puis des fois il prend la parole dans
les podcasts sexe oral watts et les
podcasts des lisant des jaunes ils sont
tarés si bons qu'ils les filles
reçoivent le pauvre est beaucoup de
messages ont vu nick déjà entendre sa
voix
genre je voudrais couché avec toujours
excitant de savoir à quoi fait du
sexting parmi ces seules affaires je me
mêle
je commence cette semaine je venais
d'être pétuaud nous est ce que 2 va
faire des exemples de sont de son
sexting qu'on va mettre les
exclusivement aux étudiants j'ai envie
d'être là et merci merci d'avoir écouté
ce podcast jusqu'à la fin de ce père que
vous avez apprécié la conversation ça
prouve que vous êtes de réelles fans de
conversation et du sans-fil pas de
casser on vous remercie vraiment
beaucoup
si vous voulez avoir plus de contenus
plus de conversations sur pétillante que
ça se passe
hier sur p tu es a non seulement on met
tous les podcasts en ligne au moment où
est ce qu on les tourne donc on a
beaucoup de semaine d'avant sur le
pétrole mais on fait aussi des encore
moins de filtres qui sont exclusifs au
monde pète urnes puisque on parle
d'hommes que l'émoi de la conversation
qu'ont bien d'avoir ce qu'on met un peu
plus en profondeur dans certains sujets
qu'on voulait aborder ou qu'on abordait
pendant le podcast donc allez sur notre
page rituels et le lien vers savoir dans
la description du podcast qui remercie
encore une fois de nous avons écouté
jusqu'à la fin